my name is Rutger Bregman I'm a
historian and in my humble opinion been
men and women should be paid more than
bankers so a good way to illustrate this
point is to look at a couple of strikes
to happen through our history so for
example in New York 1968 there was a big
strike of Vinh men they were just angry
that their wages were not going up
anymore
so they said you know what we're gonna
go on strike and you'll see just how
important we are
and indeed six days later you know the
state of emergency had to be declared
New York really couldn't handle it turns
out you can't do without been that two
years later in Ireland there was another
strike in this case of bankers it's the
only strike that I know of throughout
history of where the bankers actually
went in Australia and all the experts at
that point all the economists they all
predicted disaster this was supposed to
be like a heart attack for the economy
the thunder strike started and nothing
much happened really it actually lasted
for six months in the end so the garbage
collectors were instruct for six days
state of emergency
bankers going struck for six months then
nothing which happens you know the
economy just kept growing businesses
kept operating there are nowadays many
people in professions in say Wall Street
or Silicon Valley that you know are
often described as the visionaries in
the whiskas who come up with all these
wonderful products there was someone at
Facebook who worked there for years and
said the best minds of my generation are
thinking about how to make people click
and you know that's that's one of the
tragedies of our times that we're
wasting so much talent there are so many
smart people right now in jobs that
don't contribute anything and it's not
necessary it's not inevitable we need to
rethink who the real wealth creators
actually are in our society so there's
some fascinating research actually new
research from two Dutch economists max
Finland and Robert from durable looked
at this whole phenomenon of what they
call socially useless jobs they asked
people the question do you think your
job is actually valuable do you
contribute anything to
good turns out that in modern economists
develop economies 25% of the work Flores
says I don't know maybe no probably not
if I go on strike no one really cares
now who are these people is an
interesting question turns out that
actually they have wonderful LinkedIn
profiles you know they have wonderful
excellent salaries they're often at the
top of the pyramid you know their
bankers corporate lawyers consultants
basically you know a lot of people
sitting in offices all day sending
emails to people they don't like writing
reports no one's ever going to read but
still making a lot of money so that's
quite fascinating right that the rest of
the population is supporting this or
class of people you know who don't
really contribute anything right what
we're doing is we're spending billions
of pounds to educate our best and
brightest and they go to office for an
in Cambridge and then they go on and
they do jobs that they absolutely don't
like I mean it's not me saying it's
people themselves saying it or they
don't really contribute anything what's
going on here who are the real wealth
creators and the reality here is I think
is that we're living in an inverse
welfare state where most wealth is
actually created at the bottom by people
who are doing the real work the teachers
the nurses the garbage collectors you
name it
this state of affairs it's not
inevitable we can change it and I would
like to live in a society where we
actually pay people according to their
contribution right where we have a real
meritocracy and in such society I
believe in the long run been men and
woman would be paid more than bankers
you